In this video, I'm going to teach you
step-bystep how to create a YouTube
automation video using
I found an amazing AI tool that [music]
can generate 10 short videos every 30
minutes. Today, I'll be showing you how
to recreate
the fastest way to create. We're going
to use two AI.
[music]
I hate AI videos. Open any social media
and start scrolling. Half of the videos
you'll see are made with AI. An AI voice
commenting on a funny video. An AI text
that's showing a random motivational
quote. AI image slideshow. A video with
AI script, AI voiceover, [music] AI
captions, AI footage, AI music. They're
breaking the internet. And I'm not okay
with it because they're soulless,
boring, inconsistent. They make us dumb.
So that they could take over the world.
I don't know. Maybe.
But it's AI. You know, the biggest
revolution in human history since the
invention [music] of Bitcoin.
So what?
Think about it. Isn't there a better way
to use it? There has to be a better way
to use it, right? We just need [music]
to find it.
He was right. So I spent the next few
months searching all over the internet
to find a way to make better AI videos.
And after dodging around 1,000 videos
teaching how to make 300 shorts in
[music] 30 minutes with Chad GBT and
Canva, I think we got something.
It turns out it's not a brand new thing.
People have been making cinematic AI
videos for the last few years, but they
all have some big problems. [music] The
art style in each shot looks completely
different. The characters don't look the
same. The story is too AI generated, and
most importantly, they don't [music] get
views. We need to fix them all.
Here's the plan. I will try to create a
video with AI completely from scratch,
upload it to a new channel and see how
many views I can get.
Before starting this video, I asked you
guys for ideas. Here are all the cool
video concepts that you came up with.
Animated scenes with full emotions and
add some emotions.
Emotions. Okay. Emotions.
Consistent.
Characters.
Editing.
Show me your edit.
Editing. I like pterodactyls. If you
have a pterodactyl in the movie, I will
watch it.
All right, pterodactyls. A I got you,
man. Thanks [music] to everybody for
sending their ideas. Now, the next step.
Wait, what? [screaming]
[music]
I know this guy. Nope. Now, these are
great ideas, but we need more [music]
context.
I wrote the story with Chat GPT's ideas
and tweaked some parts a [music] little
bit. It turned out pretty well. You can
pause to read it, but we're going to see
it at the end anyways. So,
now I already made a video about
thumbnails. But since we're making a
video with AI, we got to make an AI
thumbnail, too. So, ladies and
gentlemen, introducing the channel's
very first sponsor, Pixels. It's an AI
image generator that's trained
specifically on YouTube thumbnails so
that with a single prompt it can
generate stuff like this or this or
this. All right, let's create our
thumbnail. Our video is going to be
about time travel. So create a dramatic
thumbnail with turbulent close up on a
running bearded ginger man centered in
the middle on his feet. He has a slight
dinosaur background the overall motion
going on. Pretty impressive for 10
seconds of work. [music] Even if you
know how to create it in Photoshop, it
would take hours to create something
like this. But it doesn't stop here. You
can click this button and edit the
thumbnail with your own words. Let's add
some muscles [music] to our guide. Ah,
that's a bit too much. Perfect. If you
have a face in the thumbnail, [music]
like this one, you can replace it with
your own face by just clicking this
button.
You can even search for a thumbnail
concept that already worked on YouTube
and [music] just paste the video link
here. The AI will analyze it and come up
with a slightly different [music]
concept. Pixels recently released a new
feature for helping you generate titles
as well. Just write what you have in
mind and it will come up with really
impressive [music] title variations.
They're constantly improving the
algorithm with the new pixels 2.0
updates. [music] The results look 10
times more impressive. You can even add
a custom text to the thumbnail, a
feature that almost no other AI tool is
able to do at this point. It has more
features coming soon like adding your
own photos, [music] even creating a
thumbnail from your sketch. You can
check out Pixels with the link in
description and with the code Isaac,
you'll get a 50% discount for the first
month or use Isaac year for 33% on the
yearly plan. It's only valid for [music]
the first 200 people, so go use it
while you still can.
So, thank you Pixels [music] for
sponsoring this video. Now that we got
our title and thumbnail, let's move on
to the next step.
Before doing anything else, we need to
plan what we want to create. So, I used
my impressive drawing skills to make
this thing called storyboard. Almost
every [music] professional filmmaker
uses this technique to plan their shots
before actually taking it. So, why not
make it for AI films? [music] The key is
that it has to be easy to understand.
After a few hours of work, here's what
they look like.
There are dozens of AI video generators
[music] out there, but the most popular
ones are called Stable Diffusion, Pick a
Labs, Runway, and Sora. The results from
this one look great, but it's not
released to the public yet, [music] so
we can't use it. Stable diffusion looks
like a bit. It makes the videos using
your computer's and the UI looks a bit
okay. It's [music] too complicated.
These two are almost the same thing with
only slight differences in style.
Basically, Runway is more cinematic
while Piccolabs has [music] more
cartoonish vibes. I gave them the exact
same prompt, and these are the videos
they made. I like the Runway style,
though. You can try both [music] and see
which one works for you. But it's not
important for now because after this
video, you can use any software with the
same principles. So instead of breaking
down all the technical [music] stuff
about the software, we will just learn
what we need and focus on turning the
ideas into videos. As you might guess,
you can generate videos in three
different ways. From text, from an
image, and from a video. We don't have a
video yet, so [music] text to video is
nice for generating quick B-rolls for
your videos, but it's hard to predict
the results if you're looking for a
consistent style and characters. So, the
plan is we will generate images using AI
and animate it with another AI. It's
going to be a piece of cake. No god,
that doesn't make any sense.
I'm going to use MidJourney here because
everyone says it's the best image
generator out there, but you can use any
software you want. First, get a
subscription. Go to Discord, create a
new server, and add the MidJourney bot
to the server. That way, you can see all
the images you generate in a single
place. Now it's time to see what this
thing can do. Write slash imagagic and
uh I haven't used it for a while. Let me
catch up with the updates.
I read all the update notes they shared
on their Discord. I know boring stuff.
Then I watched a few hundred videos on
how to use. Here are some cool channels
I found the most valuable information
from. I tried to apply what I learned to
the actual software. And to be honest,
most of the images turned out bad,
creepy, even kind of suspicious. But
with practice, they started to get
pretty good. And a few hundred attempts
later, here's the strategy I came up
with to generate the scenes.
First, type / settings and choose
midjourney version 6 or whatever is the
latest version right now. Then,
experiment with the most basic prompts
you can think of and see what they do.
At the end of each prompt, add-
if you want to generate them in
landscape mode, or- arx6 for short. Now,
after each image, we get some buttons
below. The ones at the top increase the
resolution and the bottom line creates
slightly different variations. When you
upscale the one you like, more buttons
appear. Just try them once and you'll
figure out what they do. All right,
these are a good starting point, but it
isn't really possible to control much of
the results this way. We need to get
more specific.
We can tell the AI where we want our
character. Instead of asking it to
generate an image of a bearded ginger
man, we can add a background based on
our story. Now, let's add one more
person to the shot. Tell where you want
them to stand in the shot and what they
do.
After getting the basics, the next step
is adding more details. You can do it by
adding some adjectives and writing more
detailed character description. That was
the last prompt we wrote. Let's see what
else we can add. A charismatic
30-year-old adventurer man is watching
the Giza pyramid in ancient Egypt while
his dog wanders around. man has a lean
and a long ginger hair, wearing a light
gray shirt with black cargo pyramid is
made of glass.
All right, let that sink in.
We can add much more details to our
prompts like time of the day, season,
color scheme, and so on.
Most of the characters made by
Midjourney lack emotion in their faces.
I mean, is this guy happy, confused,
confident? None of them. He just exists.
So, it's always nice to specify the
character's emotion in your prompt.
Happy, sad, scared, angry, confused,
disgusted, [music] jealous, guilty,
fury. You know what I mean?
In an actual movie, each shot has a
certain camera angle. That's what makes
them look cinematic. We can get a
similar effect by writing some keywords
to our prompt. I like this one. It's all
up to what style you're looking for.
Speaking of styles, you probably noticed
almost every single image has a
different style. Some are realistic,
others are more animation-like or
illustration. It's cool, but when we
animate these, we can't really make them
look like a part of a single video. So,
we need to give them a single style.
AI image generators usually make photos
in between realistic and [music]
animated looks. I don't know what it's
called, but it kind of became the
signature of AI. If you want to avoid
this style, you may go towards either
side [music] or try totally different
art styles to get something unique.
First, let's go with the realistic. You
can add a movie genre to give it a
certain vibe. fantasy, sci-fi, comedy, I
don't know, or a director name that has
his own style, like Wes Anderson, who's
known for his symmetric shots and weird
colors. Tim Burton, Edgar Wright, James
Cameron, Spielberg, or any director you
like. I don't know much about cameras,
but I saw most people like to add a
camera type [music] in their prompts
like that. Or we can go the opposite way
and get more animated style with words
like Pixar, animation, [music] or 3D.
Other styles can be oil paintings,
watercolors, anime, comics, 2D cartoons,
surreal, van, cubism, cyber, black and
white, renissance, pencil art, sketch,
Japanese art, I don't know. There are
countless art styles you can choose
from. Pick the one you like and add it
to your prompt. But wait, it's still AI.
And AI is not consistent. Even if you
write the exact same [music] prompt, it
will give slightly different styles each
time. But don't worry, there's a
solution for that.
[music]
It turns out you can give Midjourney a
reference image to look for. So it would
generate all other images with a [music]
similar style. Now I want you to give
your full attention to this point
because we're about to get a bit
technical. Hey, turn off the music. All
right, you got this. You got this. Let's
take this shot. Upscale. Upscale again.
Open in browser. Download. Upload to
Discord. Now write your prompt as usual.
Then just like d- AR16x9,
write d- [music] sf. Hit space and drop
your image next to it. That was a style
reference. It will copy its style to the
new image. We need to learn a few more
parameters. D- [music]
S is called stylize value. It shows how
much midjourney can add its imagination
to your image. The default [music] is
100 and the maximum value is a 1,000.
Let's try something like 500
dash ca value. It's like the
unpredictability of the results. Zero
makes them almost the same. And the
shots get different as [music] long as
you increase this value up to 100. Style
raw minimizes the improvisation and only
follows [music] your prompt. With all
this knowledge, hopefully you can get
any image in your mind with the best
[music] accuracy. But the biggest
problem is still there since the very
beginning. This is not the same guy. If
we want to make a video out of these, we
need a consistent character throughout
all the results.
Yeah, that's the hard part. What's your
plan?
Hey, you have a plan, right?
Look, I'm going to be honest. I watched
all the tutorials about that, but none
of them gets the perfect result. The
images always turn [music] out slightly
different each time, and the process is
too complex. I don't want that. I
actually don't know what to do at this
point.
Don't worry, man. There's still time.
You can figure it out.
Can I? Yeah, I can.
I couldn't figure it out.
Maybe I should move on to another
tutorial. A tutorial about [music] how I
edit.
Nah, nobody would watch that.
Having a bad day.
Yeah, I [music] think we had this
conversation before. Don't even start.
Yeah, I'm not here to give you a
motivational speech this time. [music]
Just wanted to know how's your AI
project going.
Uh, not good, man. It's clear it's not
going to work out. It's not the end of
the world if I'm not going to check off
everything on the list, right? [music]
I'll just accept and move on.
Hey, hey, hey. No. Look, you have to
finish this video. You hear me?
Otherwise,
why is it that important for you
anyways?
That's not the point. If you were going
to quit, why did you come this far?
I don't know.
It's time to finish what we started.
So with this new feature, just like d-
sref, we can give a reference character
to our prompt by typing d-cref. so it
can generate scenes with the same
character every time. First, we need a
reference character to use in all our
images. To do that, generate your
character based on what you learned
until this point. A like '90s anime
style portrait of a 30-year-old bearded
ginger man with green eyes. The man is
wearing a light gray shirt. Here's the
crucial part. Split into four images
shot from different angles. It will give
you something like this. Upscale the one
you like. Take screenshots of each angle
and upload it to Discord. Now, it gets a
bit technical. Stay with me. We can
still use Cref command and paste each
image link one by one. But doing that
for every single image can be a bit
annoying if you're going to do it a 100
times. So we're going to create our own
command. Sounds complicated, but all
we're going to do is instead of Cref and
links next to it, we will create a
custom keyword so that when we write it,
it will understand we mean this command.
Write/prefer option set. Inside the
option box, write your character's name.
Click plus one and select value. Here
write the command d- cref and paste your
reference image links. Now each time I
write dash- Isaac, it will create the
image based on the these images.
Finally, of course, you don't need to
use all of these in all your prompts,
but by using as much detail as possible,
you'll get closer to the image in your
head, which I guess is the main purpose
of AI tools, isn't it? Anyways, I
repeated the same process for the rest
of the shot. And here are the images
we're going to use. Yeah, you better be
watching this, man. I got a pterodactyl
for you. Now, we need to turn these into
actual videos. Uh uh, we're a bit behind
the schedule.
The video part turned out to be easier
than I expected. As I said in the
beginning, I used Runway for that part.
It gives you some free credits, but
you're probably going to need a
subscription after some point. Anyways,
here's what I [music] did. This is the
main page. When you open up your
account, click on generate videos and
choose Gen 2 image [music] to video.
After uploading the image you generated
in Midjourney, write your prompt. Unlike
Midjourney, I saw it works best if you
write very simple prompts like the man
looking up because we already did most
of the heavy lifting [music] with
images. Here we need to adjust the
camera motion and motion brush tools
based on our scene. Camera motion is
well controls the motion of the whole
shot. Tweak them slightly based on your
image and move on to the motion brush
tool. This is where the magic happens.
Choose the specific parts you want to
move and brush them with different
colors like head, hands, the entire
character, dog, sky, and building. Then
use these sliders to decide which
direction [music] you want them to move.
Again, don't go too extreme with these
or you might [music] get some extreme
results. Before hitting generate, tick
this check box to get the final video
with higher FPS and
I mean, it's not bad at all for a raw
video, but it's going to get better. I
repeated the same process for the rest
of the images. A quick note from the
future. I actually tried animating the
rest of the shots, but even though the
first few videos were quite nice, as
soon as I tried some illustration style
images, yeah, I mean, what's that?
However, when I tried the same thing
with PALabs, it handled it way better.
The settings here are almost the same as
runway, so the learning curve is a few
minutes. So, [music] realistic or 3D
images for runway, cartoon or anime
style for PALabs. Now, we can continue.
And lastly, I used 11 Labs to get the
voiceovers needed for the story, just
like the voice you're listening to right
now. And yeah, if you didn't realize
it's AI until this point, welcome to the
club. There's a link in the description
if you want to try it yourself. Now, we
need to edit them together.
I will make a full guide on editing
soon. So, it's just a quick overview of
what I did to edit this video. Step one,
put the voiceovers into order and cut
the pauses. Step two, find a nice music
that fits in the story and add it to the
timeline. Step three, add the AI
generated video clips based on the voice
over and music. Try to keep the flow
between music and the visuals. Step
four, add zooms, camera movements, and
transitions if needed. Step five, add
extra details like smoke, dust, or
lighting overlays. Step six, add some
sound effects to important points. If
you're new to this, just use a popular
sound effect pack from YouTube. Or if
you need something [music] more
specific, again, search for it on
YouTube. Step seven, cover everything
with an adjustment layer and add the
lummetric color effect on it. Play with
the colors to get the vibe you want.
Step eight, if you want more cinematic
look, add a crop effect on the
adjustment layer and increase the top
and bottom values. Step nine, export the
final video. It's showtime.
It's been 1 week since I released the
video, but before showing the results,
we need to talk. So, the AI video and
all that is cool, but the real question
is, where are you going to use these? Is
making story videos like these a good
idea? Probably not. Wait, so all that
stuff was for nothing?
Hey, did you really pay attention to the
entire video? [music]
[music]
Heat. Heat.